Demokratie ist ein kompliziertes
Verfahren dass seine Reihe von
Voraussetzungen hat wir haben ja vorhin
schon sozusagen über Arbeit etwas in der
Arbeitsgesellschaft gesprochen und
Demokratie lebt davon dass Menschen
bereit sind sich zu engagieren für die
Demokratie wenn wir über den Untergang
und Zerfall von Demokratie entsprechen
dann gucken wir in der Regel auf äußere
Feinde oder auf innere Gegner aber wir
haben zu wenig im Auge das ist so etwas
wie ein stillzweigenden Rückzug von
vielen Bürgerinnen und Bürger aus der
Politik gibt die sich nicht mehr
engagieren die nicht mal mehr zur Wahl
gehen wenn ich meine Jugend denke wo
bunte bei Bundestagswahlen eine
Wahlbeteiligung von hohen 80
gelegentlich 90 Prozent waren und man
heute darauf schaut sozusagen es zeigt
dass Demokratie in der Gefahr steht von
innen heraus zu trocknen
und das ist jetzt im Prinzip nichts
Neues denn wenn wir mal sagen Bürger
partizipative Ordnungen also Ordnungen
in denen die ein Teilhabe der Bürger
eine Voraussetzung für das Funktionieren
das Systems es hat es immer gegeben aber
es ist auch häufig untergegangen
zerfallen an dem was
Etienne laboesie also ein der Freund von
montania
Service
Knechtschaft genannt hat nicht sozusagen
man bekommt das Angebot ach du musst
dich ja gar nicht drum kümmern das
genügt ja wenn du ein konsumistisches
Verhalten zur Politik hast guckst welche
Partei gefällt dir wie ein Käufer im
Supermarkt schaut und die Preise
miteinander vergleicht und so weiter und
gleichzeitig sozusagen während der Input
der Bürger immer geringer wird wird aber
die Erwartung an die Politik was sie
alles so leisten hat immer größer nicht
mehr haben wir es mit der klassischen
Schere zu tun
und solche Scheren sind das Problem von
Ordnungen und das ist etwas was mich
besorgt und wie sie gesagt haben auch
bedrückt Bela spürst du diese Schere
auch ja ich habe das Buch das
Professor Münkler geschrieben hat
gelesen tatsächlich großartig ja finde
ich sehr interessant da sind auch viele
interessante historische Ministerin aber
ich glaube sie haben eine aber ich
sozusagen als kerntees entnommen dass
der Bürger sich mehr engagieren sollte
in der Politik also medienkompetenz ist
das eine und das andere ist eben mehr
Engagement aber ich glaube Politik macht
es im Bürgerinnen und Bürgern wirklich
nicht leicht sich zu engagieren weil in
vielen Parteien ist noch das alte
Verfahren der eine protegie den einen
der andere produziert den anderen man
muss sich hochziehen in Hinterzimmern
schwer einen Saufen immer noch ja wird
ja würde man ja machen das glaube ich
schon aber die Lebenswirklichkeit von
Menschen ist einfach eine ganz andere
von jungen Menschen auch die sind autark
die sind unterwegs die wechseln alle
zwei drei Jahre ihren Wohnort auch
irgendwie gar nicht mehr in diesen
Strukturen da agieren können die aber
gefordert sind immer noch von der
Politik und deswegen Buben solche
Organisationen wie Fridays for future
viele von diesen NGOs nicht
Regierungsorganisationen die natürlich
viel viel moderner Strukturen haben die
mit vernetzt sind überall die auch sowas
gar nicht voraussetzen sich da immer
hoch zu buckeln und da ist glaube ich
Politik wirklich im Hintertreffen und
wenn sich diese Strukturen nicht ändern
dann haben wir wirklich einen
Nachwuchsproblem oder die Hälfte kommt
eben aus dem öffentlichen Dienste im
Bundestag sitzen ja also ich meine sie
haben noch mal darauf hingewiesen nicht
Regierungsorganisationen die machen es
den Leuten leicht entweder indem sie
sagen ihr habt ein gutes Gewissen wenn
ihr uns ordentlich Geld spendet und wir
machen dann da spektakuläre Aktionen
teilweise mit Industriekletterern und
anderen wie das eine Zeitlang von
Greenpeace ja praktiziert worden ist
oder auf der anderen Seite ihr klebt
euch mal irgendwo an oder werft Suppe
gegen ein
das darf man auch nicht so nur nur so
abtun weil die haben natürlich auch
Strukturen die flexiblen sind die atmen
sind wo ich mich engagieren kann wo ich
mich verletzen kann beispielsweise Junge
Union junge Liberalen die wollen ja auch
so weniger
und ich habe da wirklich ja nur bin ja 9
Jahre mit dabei und wir haben sind ja in
Berlin noch angetreten ja damals mit den
Freien Wählern ich habe gesagt okay ich
bringe den Kinderschutz in Berlin rein
die Wahlen Demokratie in Berlin mit den
Wahlen lassen wir mal ganz schnell weg
aber fakt ist wenn man das so mitbekommt
wie ist denn so abläufig kommen wir nun
machen viel mit dem Thema Mobbing wie
läuft es ab nur ja also wenn du nicht
Partei treu bist und auch nicht immer zu
einem Jahr und Abend sagst oder
vielleicht mal wieder Wort hast dann
wirst du schon mehr geschafft
ausgegrenzt spricht man manchmal mit dir
und mach dir eigentlich klar da ist der
Weg ja also zuerst kommt die Partei und
dann kommst irgendwann mal du und
Idealismus so dass man einfach
vielleicht doch mal was verändern will
ist nicht unbedingt gefragt also man
muss ein guter Soldat sein eigentlich
glaube ich ein Knecht